[Music]
welcome back folks welcome back to your
[Music]
last episode
of yang speaks
without your front man andrew yang
speaking without yank speaking i
understand there's a uh there's a reason
you tune in to yank speaks for injury
gang but you've got yours truly zach
grauman and carly riley who i thought we
had filled in pretty admirably during
let's call it the andrew yang hiatus
thoughts carly sure i i you know i think
there are some people who hate us and
some people who love us and uh we're
okay with both and i'm really
appreciative there there have been a
number of people who have reached out
and said yeah we're gonna plug here yang
speaks or i'm sad you'll not be hosting
co-hosting anymore so uh
yeah we'll take the win
the episode we're gonna dive in about
what's next for both us and this podcast
um but on today's episode of yang speaks
for timeout are you elite universities
selecting just blatantly selecting more
uh people on the left which is something
the press is not covering very much i
think it's really interesting uh we're
gonna talk about flying cars we need to
be talking about more flying cars it's
freaking awesome uh and carly's gonna
make cryptocarly is gonna make a crypto
call which makes me excited as well max
trying very hard to make crypto carly a
thing it is a thing and
look uh we mainly try to make um
to talk about things that are not being
covered very well by the press either um
in volume or accuracy so
we got universities flying cars crypto
carly
and some fun
next steps about yang's book tour the
forward uh activities and things like
that so let's dive in
carly i want to talk about um i want you
to talk about
matthew iglesias kind of wrote um an
interesting piece that is not and he
always gets a good amount of play on his
own articles but it's not catching
mainstream but it's about who's going
into our universities and what the
implications are so let's dive in the
harvard crimson right the harvard
newspaper i guess every year newspaper
right the student newspaper yep it does
a survey of the incoming freshman class
so this is the class now of 2025 that's
incoming
um and as part of that survey they ask
anonymously about people's ideological
leanings and so this year's survey
revealed that 87
of the incoming harvard class voted for
joe biden compared to 6.7 percent who
voted for howie hawkins and 6.3 percent
who voted for donald trump
um so i think there's there's a couple
things to note here i think one and and
matthew iglesias makes this point is
there's a narrative that our
universities
are like brainwashing students into
being like far lefties i think one thing
this demonstrates is
they're also pre-selecting
for lefties
so
you know it's not that they're
necessarily being
brainwashed during school but they've
sort of only selected for a certain
number of a certain type of of person to
begin with and those numbers extend
beyond just harvard right it's like yale
similar i think dartmouth was it was the
best quote-unquote in terms of your if
you believe in optimizing for diversity
of ideology um
but yes like it's it's pretty consistent
now look young people tend to skew more
liberal right grenan sustrin who is a uh
reporter she had a post recently saying
hey have you gotten more conservative or
more liberal as you've gotten older and
over time and like it's all people
saying they got more conservative so
this isn't i think this can be blown out
of proportion but i do think it's really
uh it's really telling and as somebody
who went to school was in college you
know within the last 10 years i can say
it felt kind of oppressively left
dominant
again i came into college very very
left-leaning and i actually came out of
college a little bit more of a moderate
centrist because i'm a contrarian and i
was surrounded by so much like far
leftism that i i sort of it pushed me a
little bit more in the other direction
um
so i do think that there's something to
be made of the sort of
fear around colleges being so
ideologically
non-diverse
um and i do think they the the the the
the second piece to this that i thought
was really interesting is there's this
new report that came out that matthew
glacier also mentions in this article
we'll link the article um
that's that said one of the features
that does seem to
i'm saying get worse right
during people's college years is their
sense of moral absolutism so they're
coming in
democrats
and then and like sort of to the left of
the spectrum and then over the course of
their four years they become morally
more morally certain of their ideology
and i think that's really the thing that
i chafe against i think you chafe
against it i imagine a number of our
listeners chafe against it is this not
just that you're on the left but that
you feel so self-righteous and morally
superior
in those views and you're so intolerant
of anybody who deviates from
what you see is the acceptable worldview
and
that in young people who are supposed to
be the more open-minded ones i think
that is is more concerning to me than
just
these education these institutions like
selecting for democrats it's no longer
your political opinion
it's
you're correct you're just right um
you're a good person and and somebody
else and anyone just agrees is morally
wrong more like bankrupt um
and
there's no room for compromise enough
room for debate there are
plenty of like right-leaning or moderate
folks that voted for joe biden so like
voting for bride number trump doesn't i
think it's not as clear-cut um in terms
of right or left as maybe prior election
point you know if you take the
fundamental values of conservatism and
liberalism where you're like liberals
believing
fairness and
fairness and helping those that were
disadvantaged and caring um yeah
having a strong social safety net and
government to solve the biggest problems
and conservative believing kind of
limited government and a meritocracy and
preventing government overreach
and
being a little more pro-business and
pro-capitalism um that government will
screw that up like those are um neither
of those are to be morally wrong they've
been debated for
centuries um um
frankly i think here here's the the two
final things i i
think are interesting about this piece
um
well one i think it's it's the
implications of this because i think the
implications go two ways
the first is
what we're sort of seeing and what you
and i talk a lot about in media
newsrooms right like you're seeing the
graduates of these schools because
they're they came in left-leaning and
then they grow only sort of more morally
absolute about their beliefs as they go
through college they then come into
newsrooms and their first jobs and
and you sort of get what we're seeing
right which is like ideological capture
in media
and then i think you also have an
implication that i think barry weiss is
talking a lot about right which is now
what this what the feeder schools to
these elite institutions are doing which
is there
these parents don't want to speak up
against
maybe woke ism gone too far in some of
these educational institutions because
they want their kids to get into these
top schools you know they sort of
understand on some level that
clearly like you know you're advantaged
if you're indoctrinated in liberal
things but the last thing i'll say
because i love this because because at
the end matthew iglesias concludes this
article really more with like a word to
the wise for conservatives which i
really appreciate because i think it is
it's like we should act
there's so much to not just scold
conservatives about but like that is
actually just despicable about what the
republican party pushes i mean we've
talked about the abortion thing i i had
sent
a clip of republican lawmakers talking
about abortion and rape and it's like
horrendous
um and so
what he talked about there is like it
does not help
democrats win elections
to have all of the people coming out of
these elite institutions be like super
liberal and because that's exactly what
the republicans use to rile up their
base is like [ __ ] these elites who think
they're better than you you know all
these people coming out of harvard blah
blah blah
uh however his he says it doesn't
actually like conservatives
actually do want the the approval call
of the cultural mainstream like they
want their own values reflected in
marvel movies and in beer commercials
like they want to see republican values
in culture and they complain about the
lack of that like a lot
and he was like
so but and yet you
don't throw any bones
to
like young people in some way right like
you you really do do everything in your
power to make yourself seem like right
uncaring unfeeling sociopaths which are
like especially
uh irritating and unappealing to
wide-eyed young people
you have to go to college get a job and
um take out a bunch of student loans and
then they take out the loans the jobs
aren't there they have a mountain of
debt they can't buy a home like they're
pissed off right and they're not pissed
off from
they feel like maybe the system's
already immoral
they've just come from an institution
where everybody's feeling the same way
and they're all all leaning a certain
direction there's certain community that
comes from that the one thing that's i
wanted to say is that i i don't know if
everybody always connects these dots
like where do the what do the people
that graduate from these elite
institutions end up doing they end up
like we're taught let's let's call it 30
years from now they end up running
all of your fortune 500 companies they
end up starting the new facebooks and
apples and got xyz's they end up getting
the high level jobs at every consulting
firm and political organization in the
country like this is who these people
are that's what they do they end up they
they thrive in they're very very smart
and they're very driven and they were
great at school and they have great
support systems whatever the privilege
you want to say the reality is they end
up thriving in the economy and they end
up leading the united states of america
and if
we have moral absolutists
all leaning on the same team and a bunch
of people piling on the bottom who
disagrees strongly on the other side
it's probably a recipe for disaster to
me it's just i don't think it's going to
play out like that though in 30 years
because maybe it can become more
conservative i don't know but it is
worth talking about it's fascinating
shifting gears
i want to talk about something awesome
because politics is annoying um and
everybody gets all mad i love everyone
it's fine we all can get along i'm going
to share this planet somehow so let's
talk about something awesome and that
awesomeness carly
is flying cars
there was an announcement there's a
company called urban v
urban e-v-t-o-l which stands for carly
electric vertical takeoff and landing
e v t o
l which i guess the o
is take off
take off and then you're in got it i see
um you're so smart okay
but there's a whole
bunch of people very smart people
actually exploring flying cars so that
was an impression that we kind of gave
up on the flying car thing and we were
like you always see the memes it's like
oh in the future in two in 2020 we'll
have flying cars and you're looking at
us and like we're getting you know we do
it instacart but we still have
uh
you know we can't even figure out voting
machines but flying car is a real thing
and so this um urban evitol i don't know
if that's i wonder like i want i want to
know how they
pronounce it internally i mean we can
try to get ceo on here in the future um
but evtol
they have a new flying car
it's an electric propulsion
uh
they're like a specialist a super car
designer they've partnered up basically
like the electric
propulsion specialist and the super like
awesome car designer i've teamed up and
they've created this
three-seat
flying car
that can claim claims they can go 250
miles an hour
uh top speeds and
cover basically a 300 mile radius is
pretty crazy
and we'll show you the design but the
design you can literally
like you can fly it into your garage
like it's this little simple view like
come on in like they're gonna have test
models out next year 2022 and they're
targeting to 2026 to have this thing
available which is nuts um
now there's a bunch of these cars out
there like uber's trying some stuff and
a whole bunch of things and you can see
them you google these you'll see like
basically they look like futuristic
helicopters
um and i know elon musk has talked about
this type of tech where it's the issue
is the um
how loud they are um because you have to
there's that much force needed so
there's a it's a
physics kind of almost like a sonic boom
like the amount of energy you need that
creates a loud noise no one wants that
in their suburban neighborhood wherever
they're parking their car let me ask you
this cryptocarly um
as your with your investment eye like
do you think we'll ever get to flying
cars like actually used in practice or
is it just gonna be like
rich people with their pilot's license
will be able to to fly this [ __ ] kind of
like uh different than drones but like
similar to where they're like their use
case is like
niche in in a way no i think we'll get
there
think so like yeah i mean
you know i don't know this industry well
so it it's something very an actually
educated opinion i'd want to spend more
time on it but
yeah yeah i absolutely think we'll get
there uh it it seems to me like
with any industry it starts out being
for the rich or any industry is in like
kind of big
capital expensive
projects yeah you start with a smaller
group
and then
eventually you get to to mass production
i mean elon's the perfect example of
this right which is that yeah tesla's
the vision there has always been hey
you know use the the rich people to sort
of fund the
the operation you know and and these
things are very expensive in the
beginning and then there's just a huge
amount of money to be made in my opinion
if you can nail this so that's why i'm
optimistic is anytime you've got a huge
bag of money somewhere
the the odds that
somebody goes and collects that bag of
money at some point or very high
an electric flying car is pretty awesome
to me the tech they're talking about is
so cool where they're they're taking
some stuff that bezos did to land his
rocket where these like basically
airbags pop out underneath and you can
just like
you don't actually i mean you bounce but
you don't like bounce bounce but you
like as you land you bounce which could
prevent like
major like car crashes theoretically and
things like that but i'm thinking
like this is what we should be talking
about this is like the stuff i hate like
the little culture wars and stuff that's
crap i mean you know we all have our
passions we hate that and yet we talk
about it so much well yeah it's like
crack cocaine in some way it's also been
like you know we came from politics so
we feel like we need to talk about
politics on here but i think i both are
sort of
well now it seems like the interesting
politics but the media needs to talk
about flying cars because they are sick
and
um
so i'm gonna try and get the ceo this
bad this company on here if anyone has a
connection let me know because i think
then they talk about their strategy like
they're gonna like you target people
like specific pilots or like use cases
right so other countries that have less
like
air traffic control regulations and then
like med vacs and
uh various certification like ways to
get around certification licenses things
like that but over time i would get my
flying car license like i would get that
uh oh yeah if i could it'll be
interesting
it's gonna be regulating the airwaves
right like there's a huge
that's it that's a that's a a huge
problem in and of itself right like in
order to not like think of all the road
signs like all the the [ __ ] we have
to keep ourselves safe with vehicles
moving along the road like you can't
have like a flying
floating stop
right so so that's where it actually
gets to me that's more complicated at
least in my own head than the tech
i'm building the tech but like the how
do you actually create
airborne roadways and rules
imagine you're like chilling and like
you're working in an office
like we were just in buffalo and there's
like the big mt
was that an empty and a bank or whatever
there's a big bank building imagine
you're in like the 30th floor of that
and some like clown
drives their electric flying vehicle
into the side of your building and just
it probably wouldn't i don't know how
big this crash would be
why i'm sorry we think buffalo's
irrelevant i'm sorry no no i was just
like such a funny
like
new york whatever i'm just saying that
picking a location was uh was
i just want fun like it's not like just
new york city with flying cars all
around you're just in like a you know a
smaller city
bang there's a flying car it could be
crazy but
um the world needs to know that's why
we're talking about this podcast uh
we're a podcast of action to try and get
that guy on the pod see what happens um
okay cryptocarly you've been doing some
really cool stuff um
getting
let's call it the noobs into the crypto
world uh and they've gone pretty well so
tell me what you're doing what you're
selling what you're buying i'm selling
no you mean crypto wise okay um
my problem is i i'm not i'm not good at
selling i like buy things and then i
just hold on for dear life it's true
forever waiting like i said liquidity i
know
let's get a house i know
i won't sell um
most people who probably listen to this
pod no i'm like deep down the rabbit
hole at this point in crypto and nfts
i'm just obsessed and i'm actually
thrilled because i i thought for a long
time
that i was never gonna find
sort of the
i don't say my passion because i i kind
of hate that term and
but like that sort of one place i wanted
to play in for a long time like working
on the campaign working with andrew yang
was
just amazing and i'm so grateful for
that opportunity but i also was clear
that i didn't want to stay in politics
for but forever
well i just didn't want to stay in
politics i mean that's a oh that's you
got to love that to want to live the
campaign life
so
you know i uh
you know i was sort of
i don't know floating for for a while
trying to figure out what i really
wanted and i just feel like i found such
a home in this world and in this crypto
community and and i just the people are
awesome uh
so
with that said i i
want to bring more people into the scene
i really want to bring more women into
this scene i want more people of color
in here i mean you know there's so much
money that's going to be made in this
industry over the next 10 years like it
has everything working in its favor uh
and i just i would love like we have an
opportunity right now for to bring like
a diverse set of people into the space
and
see them hopefully you know participate
in some of those games so it's something
that i'm really excited about started
how do they where do you where do you go
well so last week i hosted
three happy hours that i were calling i
was calling like what the [ __ ] are nfts
wtf or nfts
and i did them over zoom i actually did
one it was pretty cool i ended up
partnering and doing this session as a
part of uh a summit that was taking
place last week so i got to speak to to
kind of a wider audience there
and i had i had so much fun with it if
you attended one thank you so much i
just had an absolute blast it was really
geared towards total beginners in the
space talking about why nfts are more
than just overpriced jpegs what the
bigger picture is here
how they're gonna play into all of our
lives over the next decade or two um so
if that sounds interesting i what i'm
looking at doing is extending this so i
now will do
a happy hour i think every other
thursday is what i'm looking at um
where it'll
the goal will be to be really friendly
to newcomers right so if you have a
friend if you know about crypto be a
friend who knows nothing about it send
them my way but it'll also be a place
for if you're an og and you just want to
come hang out and chat and you and i can
chat about it right like great
you're an og in the space you can you
know
teach new people creature i don't know
do you have an answer question though
how do i
so there's a link we'll include a link
we'll include a link here
notes for this podcast podcast
description okay um and it's just
whatever it's google form put your name
and email in and you'll be on my email
list and i'll be sending out updates on
when i'm doing these sessions and you
can come hang out with me it's super fun
i'm no longer going to be you know
regularly on yang speaks or at least i'm
not going to be on yang speaks every
week so if you're missing my voice
come hang out with me come sign up um
yeah it's just an amazing space and then
do you want my my like latest pick yes i
want so what um for those of us who are
a little more seasoned in the crypto
space because i own some ease uh
what should i buy i don't think i'm
gonna sell my youth i'm bullish no don't
sell your eid i mean look like
here's what i'll say
i was very confident about the the v
friends the gary v nfts those have
played panned out very very well
yep not 98 percent of projects even
projects i own like i don't have that
level of confidence in because it's hard
to know right like it it is a very
funky space
dot com bubble the other project that i
would say i've been
if not as excited close to as excited
about as the gary v1 is quite different
from the garyvee project and it's called
creature world
and
it's basically a project launched by
this 21 year old new york city-based
artist danny cole you've actually
probably seen his work zach so he he
does like graffiti art sort of around
the city but he also has these posters
there was one
on canal street
i'm trying to think like kind of like
the varric canal street intersection if
you know what i'm talking about there
zach i do you're hudson most of our
viewers we're not okay so anyway if
you're in new york city it's like right
around there and there are these posters
he would post of like his creature he's
what he calls his creatures anyhow i
just have that gut feel on it i actually
bought in at like its peak like a month
ago or something it was like i spent way
too much money i like knew i'd spent
more than i probably should but i really
believed this project it of course
proceeded to drop by a lot after i
bought it and so i was like oh i've lost
a bunch of money on this right now but
again have long-term faith in it it's
now coming back baby uh shaq shaquille
o'neal just made his profile picture a
creature and really the the way i would
just i think it's
it's a young artist who seems like a
hustler he seems like he
has a real vision he [ __ ] loves his
art
the project is is totally different than
any of the other ones in the nft space
right now he's doing really creative
things in terms of how he's engaging
with his community so right now in the
nft space the really popular thing to do
is a pfp drop that needs a profile
picture drop
where
you put forth a road map and the road
map is something like this okay hey
we're going to sell 10 000 of these nfts
it's usually some like cutesy animal
thing or some cutesy thing but it could
be anything there's only 10 000 nfts
that we want you to use as your profile
picture and once we've sold 10 of the
project we're going to give you a give
we're going to do some sort of giveaway
and you know we're going to give away
one of our nfts to our community and at
25 of the projects sold we're going to
do more giveaways and at 50 of the
projects sold we're going to make a
donation to a charity and you know and
then 100 of the project sells and then
we're going to drop merch and in the
future we're going to create a whole
story world around this and games and ip
and it's going to be amazing
and that's
so many i mean hundreds of projects that
look something like that okay this
creature world project
doesn't launch a road map if you go to
our website it's like this funky
immersive video thing that you don't
really understand what it means
but the artist has been very clear that
he's planned a whole journey for this
project from the beginning so recently
anybody who was a creature holder
woke up and got had a random
part of a playground like that was a
hand-drawn kind of part of the
playground in their crypto wallet and
basically they had to team up with other
people to kind of
build this playground in full with other
people's parts and that now unlocks the
second part of the journey like he's
just doing funky stuff and i'm really
really enjoying it so that's the project
that i'm i'm into right now check it out
creature world it's weird it's awesome
google creature world what does that
mean you google creature world nft you
should probably find it creature world
nft the other last thing i want to say
is i really want to shout out
a particular yang gang member nate
mccord who reached out to me when he
found out i was doing these
at nft educational sessions last week
and he was like hey i love this project
called axo littles and i would love to
donate axolitals to you basically for
this cause and you know you can you can
use them as giveaways during your
education sessions so i did that it
worked out
better than honestly i could have hoped
we had three awesome women each night
win and act so little in every case it
was her first nft it was her first time
getting a crypto wallet and hopefully
kind of set set them on the path of
getting more interested in this world so
just like huge big love to nate mccord
for that for the yang gang like you know
paying dividends always the actual
little project i mean he was really
excited about it because he loves the
actual little team they've been really
responsive to him so looking at the team
is always a good thing to do when you're
assessing projects but
that's really my uh my latest update on
uh
where uh i've been creature world
carly's latest
i don't know that we're not gonna put
this as a call but it is something
you're excited about we are gonna keep
bringing you on here to
talk about what what's exciting what's
um
in the crete in the creature world in
the creature crypto carly world charlie
creature crypto um
look um
let's go we're going to talk about let's
talk about what's next but a quick uh
psa for everybody uh just the fyi
because this hasn't been covered enough
digiorno the frozen pizzeria is having a
recall um
so it's not pizza it's digiorno's recall
uh if you love those commercials they're
forced to recall 28 000 pounds of
digiorno frozen pizza because it
contained soy and they didn't label it
um they also basically put like the
triple meat in the pepperoni box um
which then contains soy it wasn't
labeled so they got a bunch of trouble
so if you are a digiorno fan which i
kind of am but new york i have never in
my entire three plus years of knowing
you working closely with you and now
dating you have ever seen you eat or
mention a digiorno pizza well i will
tell you this every time i go share a
house with the boys on a trip whether
it's a wedding or a bachelor party or
just a fun weekend i
always
get a frozen pizza does your nose are
for the boys you're like why are you
getting ads like you will thank me later
then one night everybody's like wow i'm
so tired what look what do you know bang
it's not pizza it's digiorno you're
welcome so
i'm a digiorno fan it's not pizza it's
digiorno it's a terrible [ __ ] slogan
especially for like
a kind of low-grade product because all
that comes to mind is like taco bell not
being allowed to call their burrito a
beefy burrito because there wasn't
enough real beef to be consumed that's
what it feels like they're saying
they're basically it's not pizza no
literally it's not pizza it's classic
and like
um
have you ever seen that it's a little
caesars meme where they had uh hot and
ready pizza
and uh
there's like
little seed is like come get our pizza
it's hot and ready it's always like is
it good like it's hot and it's ready
but is it good well it's not ready
that's what it is hot and it's
ready all right we're saying the jokes
many times but it is funny all right
here's what's happening guys uh the cast
out bag in some ways andrew is is um
getting excited on his forward
tour um and the forward party is is
leaking everywhere as uh which andrew
will talk way more about and as he
starts uh let's call his next chapter
carly and i have been very clear we
can't stand politics but we love andrew
yang and the yang gang so we'll be let's
call it
supportively involved i'm staying
political if i can which i guess kind of
what the forward party is supposed to be
you guys should come out and see andrew
yang he's going all over the country um
andrew yang.com you click and find the
event um
that he's doing get your copy of the
book the book is very very good um i've
read it
i think part of an early draft and it
was great then so i just
imagine it's only gotten better i i have
to reading the late the final copy and i
think for a lot of you love andrew yang
it's it's like uh it's like classic yang
you know it's like him getting back to
being logical and
smarter than anybody and seeing the
world in a different way which is kind
of
cutting through the problems and the
noise and like with like a clear-minded
solution right um which is exciting so
um and so here's gonna happen andrew's
gonna be back
um
we're in his podcast mondays and
thursdays i'll be on um as your as your
hype man is every once in a while um
i think a lot of what we'll do is
probably guests on we'll have guests on
mondays and kind of yang doing current
events on thursdays
um
he's gonna start doing more emails and
for those who are early yang gangers he
would write a long email every week um
and he will be getting back to those so
um
that was early early yang gang games um
he loved writing him and i like to start
writing these bad boys again so he wrote
a couple they're pretty good so
for carly and myself
we'll be
let's call it recurring characters on
this show um and hopefully more and more
content on this network as well so i
believe cryptocarly will making an
appearance many many times as zach tries
to keep making that thing
um
and i don't know what i'll be doing um
but you'll be stuck with me i'm sure in
certain ways and i apologize in advance
but also i'm just trying to lighten the
mood most of the time
cryptocarly
it's been real
uh so for that i'd like to propose a
toast of carly's favorite peanut butter
whiskey this episode is brought to you
by super bowl it's actually not they did
not need to write this but it's very
good um so you know it's a real ad you
know it's real it's peanut butter
flavored whiskey and it's dynamite so
cheers
cheers it's been real and it's been fun
but it ain't been real fun ah
lol lol um
and then uh speaking of screwball they
are a proud sponsor actual sponsor of
the buffalo bills and speaking of the
buffalo pills
they won last weekend and it was
dynamite because
it's back i want to hear this
josh allen
it's like an asmr thing four touchdowns
in the air and one on the ground five
touchdowns guys the man
had 350 yards in the third quarter of
passing all right i'm cutting this off
no we're not getting this off it was
dynamite
thank you all so much for spending your
thursdays with me for all these many
weeks and i look forward to being back i
look forward to staying in touch with
you all i really i
i've probably made it clear i'm pretty
passionate about crypto web 3 i know a
lot of you are as well so i look forward
to staying in touch in this sort of new
capacity around a new topic a new
subject area and uh
much love to you all
cheers
bye everybody cheers
[Music]
you